that you that you oh yeah after I was
getting attacked for being Jewish
dirty the main goal of a mentor is to
pass on the energy of a
win those chosen by a mentor have the
capability to harness this energy
gorilla power for your greatest
fight brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in so if
you remember that dirt bag who ripped
the hijab of one of our sisters head
Subhan Allah in White Chapel this
flipping dirt bag who claimed to be an
IDF Soldier a little weasel that's what
they do they attacked women children and
babies that's what they know for these
dirt bags so here's the footage if you
guys don't remember but we're going to
show you another footage of him getting
CT but let's watch a video of the
incident if you guys don't know anyways
dirty
Muslim an a young girl you are V you are
below
human being dare I'm you don't want to
touch me I'm ID I don't give two flying
[__] don't touch me get him
away so you guys saw that for yourself
as you can see Subhan Allah cowards one
thing that you see a pattern with these
dirt bags is they always t Target
females they always Target sisters
because they know they can't defend
themselves they are weaker inshah that's
why it's important for us men to make
sure that we are Vigilant to females
Muslim or nonm Muslim for that matter by
the way our sister being targeted be
very Vigilant okay because um if I was
there yeah um I would have choked this
dirt bag out yes and I would have put it
cap um somewhere where the sun don't
shine um so they know what time it is
but anyways anyways uh they think that's
freedom of you know you can say things
and do things and there's no freedom of
consequence here's the video of this guy
actually being spotted on the road um
and he was sitting there I don't know if
he's a Begg I don't know who is for that
matter but this comeback was confronted
now I do not condone what happened in
the camera in the footage you're about
to see but he got attacked he got
punched in the face I'm going to
obviously sensor that but here's the
video this
one that you where you oh yeah after I
was getting attacked for being Jewish
don't about Jewish why you trying to do
that bro that's dumb little [__] can
bully some [__]
people I'll smack
you
sh so guys as you can see alhamdulillah
um yeah so again I'm not condoning any
kind of illegal behavior I'm just you
know I'm I'm a journalist I'm just
sharing this journalistic experience
with you guys um as you can see uh and
yeah um that's what happened so you need
to understand something guys individuals
like this who have so much hostility
hatred you know you can see the Venom
coming out of their mouth you need to
understand this is the same thing the
prophet peace be upon him went through
because his uncle was protected him Abu
Talib that's the reason why they
couldn't touch the prophet Muhammad
peace upon him otherwise they would have
tried to assassinate and kill him long
long time ago and you need to understand
Allah tells about the psychology of
those who hate us Muslims why because we
call to the Oneness of God why because
we tell them that this is the best way
of living they hate us and believe me
these individuals who were so venomous
if they had the power power and if there
was no ramifications and consequences
legally believe me they would be doing
exactly what Israel is doing to the
Palestinian brothers and sisters babies
children they would do
exactly exactly and that's what Allah
says in the Quran Surah that they were
only persecuting the Believers for no
other reason because they say our Lord
is one this is our only reason and Islam
is the H and people are flocking to
Islam and this this is why alhamd Allah
says in the
Quran praise Allah subhana when you see
multiple multiple of people flocking to
Islam alhamdulillah and that is exactly
what's happening the attack that we have
been going through the past 15 20 years
if it was any other religion it would
have crumbled rather Islam is the truth
and it's the H and the Hostile
Christians and Jews I'm talking about
the Hostile ones yes not all of them the
same like Allah says in the Quran the
Hostile Idol worshipers the pagans all
of them the mads you could not achieve
it Islam is still growing and
alhamdulillah dying your age and anyone
that tries to touch a sister choke them
out legally choke them out yeah let them
try to touch our sisters and see what
happens bro if that was my wife bro it
would have been your janaza in White
Chapel there would have been a memorial
for you there would be your janaza in
White Chapel bro I would have bu bury
you so deep yeah the underground
there'll be underground of the
underground of your burial bro
yeah s you can Replay that video if you
want to watch it like again I said
before I do not condone this kind of
behavior goodbye